this is a production of Cornell
University
so I'm going to start out and remind you
about what I talked about last year
which was also the practical haplotype
graph and so last year I talked a lot
about building the practical haplotype
graph in sorghum and how we were trying
to use it in a breeding program which is
run by guile press WA and based in
port-au-prince Haiti okay
and so we've used the practical
haplotype graph in that program for
genomic selection a couple times now and
in the last year really one of the
things that we've done is we've tested
the practical haplotype graph with
different genotyping methods and so
today actually what I wanted to talk to
talk about is how we've tested the pH G
and share some of those genotyping
methods and the results with and without
the practical haplotype graph ok so to
start out we have our nice genomic
selection scheme on the right here and
in any GS scheme we have this point
where we need to genotype the progeny
population and we have a lot of options
for genotyping and so this list on the
less left is absolutely not an
exhaustive list but it does list some of
the possibilities that we have but
really what we want is a technology
that's going to be cheap it's going to
be fast and we also really want a
technology that's fairly easy to use
both across breeding programs and also
across species and so when we start to
subset down this list based on those
criteria we can actually cross out a lot
of the things that are on this list to
begin with but two of the ones that are
left are are a champ seek or ramp seek
and skim sequencing and so these are two
genotyping methods that I have used with
the practical haplotype graph and so
that's what I'm gonna be presenting for
you guys today
now last year I put up a slide and I
said okay the practical haplotype graph
is really designed to be an imputation
tool and so it's been designed to work
with a lot of different types of
sequence data and I use GBS as an
example of that
I put up GPS data and I showed okay we
can use GPS for genomic selection in
guiles breeding program and we can also
use that same sequence deep data with
the practical haplotype graph in Geils
breeding program so this year I'm not
going to show you GPS data with the
practical haplotype graph but I am going
to use that GPS data as our baseline we
know that gb/s is a really an effective
technology and so we're always trying to
get prediction accuracies with new
technologies that are at least
equivalent to that okay so I'll start
actually by talking about skin sequence
and when I talk about skin sequence what
I'm really talking about is a protocol
that was designed by NextEra and
essentially they take a TN v transpose
ace that jumps into the genome at
different positions randomly across the
entire genome and then we sequence out
from those positions and so that gives
us a very sparse initial data set and
it's also completely random so we're not
capturing one specific or consistent
marker set with this technology but it
is really cheap it cost less than $10
per sample and so it is a viable option
or something that we'd like to be able
to use with with a breeding program and
so the question at the bottom then
becomes does imputation with the
practical haplotype graph make it
possible to use this technology so I'm
gonna put up this slide first this is a
plot very similar to one I showed you
last year and both in this plot and in
plots for the rest of my talk if the if
the box is blue its GBS data so that's
just the baseline okay GBS works well
for prediction accuracy in Gaia's
program now if I add in boxes for that
next Arace skim sequence data that's
those green boxes on the bottom and you
can see that yes this technology is less
than $10 per sample but it's not giving
us anything it's completely useless for
prediction okay and that really comes
down to the fact that because this is
based on random sequencing there's no
consistency there's no overlap in
positions that were we're actually
sequencing and so this is where the
practical haplotype graph can come
if we take that sequence data and we run
it through the phg to impute missing
information we actually get these dark
green boxes here and so you can see that
the practical haplotype graph is
actually helping us to restore that
prediction accuracy and we can get an
equivalent prediction accuracy
approximately the same number of markers
as we would have with GPS and we can do
it at half the cost and so the answer to
the question then is yes with skim
sequencing we can use the practical
haplotype graph for effective genomic
selection so the second technology is
ramp seek or are a champ seek this is an
amplicon based sequencing method and it
targets specific regions so it does give
you fewer markers but it's offered as a
service by a couple different companies
and that means it's very little work for
breeders to use and so we like it for
that reason
and so ramp seek when we put up a plot
like this you see that using ramp Sikma
positions or amplicons on their own
actually works really well
we're already about the same level as
GPS with this light purple those light
purple boxes and I do want to point out
that this is targeting about 2000 Llosa
across the genome and they've been
designed specifically for sorghum but
not specifically for guiles program okay
now when we take that sequence data and
we run it through the practical
haplotype graph we get these dark purple
boxes and that doesn't look so good
because you can see we're not improving
our prediction accuracy we're actually
really decreasing them and so that tells
us two things the first is that in Geils
program the 2,000 markers that we're
capturing with our a champ seek is
enough to do effective genomic selection
and the second thing is it's telling us
that with this technology right now the
practical applicable Andamanese and so
this is something that actually the
programmers have been have changed
actually how we're imputing these
genotypes and so in the next couple
months I'll be looking at if those
changes have actually improved this kind
of plot but the answer right now is that
no with ramp seek the practical
haplotype graph doesn't really help us
and isn't really necessary at all so
that brings us to this nice point where
we have
a couple different options for
genotyping and the option that a breeder
chooses really should be designed or
should be chosen based on both their
breeding goals and the budget that
they're willing to spend so I'm going to
build this plot a little bit up on the
right here on the x-axis we have the
number of snips it only goes to 3,000
but you can imagine we could extend that
fairly significantly and then on the
y-axis we have costs per sample okay so
I'll be plotting data that comes from a
group Lex genomics that's one of the
companies that produces this are a champ
seek amplicon based sequencing and as I
plot those I've also colored hopefully
you can see it okay the background of
this plot to show you at that location
in the graph what is our best sequencing
option cost wise okay and so just as an
example if we had a point where this X
is on the screen that means we want more
than 2,000 markers and we're willing to
pay more than $15 per sample and so GBS
is a good genotyping strategy in that
particular case does that make sense
great so let's add some data if we start
adding data we can see that if we're
working in a species that has a lot of
breeding efforts going on maybe we
expect that across all breeding programs
there could be 80,000 or even a hundred
thousand individuals that are being
genotyped then we're following the blue
and purple lines on this plot and
actually are a champ seek is going to be
our best bet we can get about 2,000
markers from our a champ seek and we're
still under that $10 per sample goal
that we'd like to be hitting if we're
working in a species that has more
moderate breeding efforts maybe we have
10,000 or 25,000 samples that we expect
to be genotyped then we're following the
orange and green lines on this plot and
we can really decide between ramp seek
and skim sequencing with the practical
haplotype graph both will give us a cost
effective option for genotyping and we
really want to be paying attention then
to how many markers we need because the
cost for a thousand markers is fairly
equivalent and then last if we're
working in a small breeding program
we're following the red line here and
skim sequence with the practical
photograph is really going to be the
most effective option for us in this
case I also want to point out that the
data from all right from Agri Plex only
goes up to two thousand markers but I
sort of tried to extrapolate out from
that and that's what the dotted lines on
this plot are and so if you extrapolate
out if you need more than two thousand
markers either for your breeding program
or because you want to be doing other
genomic analyses then something like GBS
or skim sequencing with the practical
haplotype graph is going to be a really
good option for you so that gets us back
to our original question when is the
practical haplotype graph most useful
and the answer is one if we're working
in a species that has fairly small
breeding efforts the pH G can help get
us cost-effective genotyping another is
that if we're working in medium or large
breeding programs but we want more than
a thousand or two thousand markers the
pH G can also help fill in some of that
marker information that we might want
and then the third is if we're working
in a breeding program or set of programs
and we want to have a consistent set of
snips the practical haplotype graph can
actually output a consistent snip set
and so that can help with that kind of
consistency as well if we need it so I
am about out of time hopefully I've
convinced you that the pH G does have
you its uses and we have used it
effectively in Geils breeding program
although I don't have time to talk about
that here there's a lot of people that
have worked on this and so I do want to
acknowledge everybody in the buckler lab
everybody in Geils program at Sheba's
and then Jeff Morris and kabedon Melita
at the Morris lab who have also put a
lot of time into this project but I'm
gonna wrap up so if you guys have
questions I'd be happy to try and
answers those now or we can talk
afterward as well thanks
[Music]
[Applause]
good question so the question was all of
the box plots I showed what are the taxa
being shown here the same the answer is
yes this is actually all data from the
training population that gaël made and
so there's about 250 taxa in that data
set and it's consistent across all of
the marker technologies great thanks
guys this has been a production of
Cornell University on the web at Cornell
edu